[Music]
these days it seems like everyone is
making money on the side
your brother drives for uber your mother
runs out your old room on Airbnb your
sister sells candles that smell like
your grandma and your grandma is running
a quilting blog almost 44 million
Americans are reported as having a side
hustle now most people start them for
one of two reasons one they want to make
more income or two they want to start
carving a path out of their current job
a side hustle can definitely help you
achieve these goals but not without
proper research and planning so here are
five things you need to know to make
sure that your side hustle won't be
hustling you
[Music]
number one do market research this is
Jenny Jenny wants to quit her job and
work for herself selling sweaters for
hedgehogs after all she's a member of
the 20,000 strong Facebook group
hedgehogs for life if just 10% of those
people bought a $30 sweater that's
$60,000
that's a nice dream but before she
starts knitting it's time for a reality
check are there people out there who are
currently making money at a venture like
this according to one study
85% of side gig workers make less than
500 bucks a month Airbnb has one of the
highest average profits of 924 a month
uber comes in at fourth and 364 and Etsy
where Jenny's Hedgehog sweaters will
probably end up is number 7 at a measly
151 bucks a month maybe Jenny should
sell a more established products like
supplements or make up with one of those
network marketing companies after all
she's got Facebook friends who are
always looking for new recruits if
you're considering joining up with a
network marketing company be extra
cautious according to a government study
only 1% of network marketing
participants actually turn a profit now
by law these companies have to share
some of their financial data with you
like average income before diving into a
new venture you should seek out every
piece of information you can get your
hands on that will give you some idea on
how much you can realistically expect to
make number to track your costs this is
Tim Tim found out that the going price
of used textbooks almost doubles around
the beginning of the school year so he
figures if he sinks his savings of 8
thousand dollars into a metric ton of
intro to biology he can sell them on
Amazon in September and double his money
not so fast him just because you're not
making a product doesn't mean you won't
have costs Tim will need somewhere to
keep all those books for the next six
which means renting a storage space each
book will have to be mailed to the buyer
which means 400 individual packing and
shipping fees and online retailers like
Amazon take a cut of every sale you make
congratulations Tim you're still making
a profit but when you calculate how much
time you're spending listing selling
packaging driving from the storage space
to the post office how much are you
really making per hour
essentially tim is the sole investor in
his own company and no smart investor
would put a single dollar into a new
venture without seeing an honest list of
expected costs and revenues what your
side hustled to be a real business
you've got to treat it like one which
brings us to number three use a separate
bank account
Kendra wanted to make some extra money
so she started driving for lyft on the
weekends after six months she had more
cash in her pocket and decided she liked
it more than her day job but since all
the costs and earnings were mixed up
with her personal finances she can't
tell whether it's a good idea to go
full-time if kendra has started a
separate bank account for her ride share
income and paid for expenses like gas
maintenance and car insurance strictly
from that account she'd have a much
clearer idea of how profitable her site
hustle really is you don't need anything
fancy just open a separate account in
your individual name at the place you're
currently baking it's a simple way to
keep track of your new income and will
make your life way easier come tax time
speaking of which number four set aside
taxes now after a year Kendra's made
enough money to put a down payment on a
new car there's just one bro this is the
most consistently nasty surprise we see
sneaking up on site hustlers they've
been making money from a new business
but I haven't put anything aside for
when the government comes knocking we
can't stress it enough do not make this
painful mistake if it's your first year
as a site hustler and you don't know how
much you'll have to pay in taxes start
by setting aside 25 percent of every
dollar you earn Uncle Sam
[Music]
after your first year of business you
will be required to pay an estimate of
your taxes on a quarterly basis just go
to this website and set up an online
account directly with the IRS believe it
or not they actually make it pretty easy
to pay them
number-5 jump with a parachute
Jenny's Hedgehog sweater company is
really taking off thanks to an
endorsement in Aaron is today aficionado
but is it safe to quit her job at the
widget Factory before she leaps out of
that plane she needs to make sure her
parachute is big enough first off does
your site hustle profit equal at least
half of what you make at your day job if
Jenny makes 30 $300 a month that widgets
Inc and her side hustle is making a
profit of two thousand a month she's
probably in a safe position to give her
two weeks notice
second does she have three months worth
of expenses saved up for emergencies 82%
of small businesses fold because of cash
flow problems and if the market for
Hedgehog sweaters temporarily dips Jenny
will need those funds to stay afloat
until it can go back up again if that
means she has to keep her day job for a
little while longer well it's better
than having to ask for it back this
might seem like a lot of work and
planning for something I was supposed to
be on the side but it's essential that
before you invest your time and money
into a new venture you understand what
you're getting into it's not uncommon
for people once they find out what's
actually involved in starting a site
business to decide they like their day
job more that's why your side hustle
should be something you genuinely like
to do after all extra money only has
value if it's contributing to your
overall happiness and that's our two
cents
you
[Music]